me llamo marks halberstadt en la escuela
siempre fui un alumno de sietes creo que
siempre fui un alumno bastante mediocre
creo que nunca me saqué una calificación
superior a 9 en ninguna clase de
matemáticas pensé que lo único que podía
hacer en la universidad era estudiar una
licenciatura en música así que me recibí
como saxofonista pero sentía más bien
que lo hice porque era muy malo en todo
lo demás
trabajé como saxofonista durante varios
años pero lo que realmente quería hacer
era ingeniería en electrónica y lo
último que recordaba que nunca había
entendido era la trigonometría así que
me metí a youtube y busqué algo sobre
trigonometría
icann academy fue lo primero que
apareció vi muchos vídeos de la lista de
trigonometría para emparejar me vi todos
los de cálculo todos los que había de
física vi muchos vídeos de cómo dividir
decimales y hasta los vídeos de la resta
por el método de pedir prestado vi
muchos vídeos de aritmética eso fue en
el 2007 lo hice hasta el otoño de 2010
en el otoño de 2010 y un salto y decidí
volver a la escuela entré a la carrera
de ingeniería en electrónica en la
universidad de tempo en la opción de
segunda licenciatura y recuerden que
nunca había sacado una calificación
superior a 9 en matemáticas de verdad yo
era un alumno de 7 es toda la vida
acabo de terminar el primer año de la
universidad con una calificación de 4.0
gpa en todo el año tuve calificación
perfecta en mis dos exámenes finales de
cálculo y también en mi examen final de
química terminé cálculo química calculo
1 y 2 y química con un promedio superior
al 100% hay algunos vídeos de khan
academy que probablemente escuche el
mismo concepto 20 o 30 veces y no hay
ningún profesor en el mundo al que le
hubiera podido pagar para que se sentara
junto a mí y repitiera lo mismo 20 ó 30
veces
sin que se hubiera desesperado cuando
menos hubiera pensado este tipo nunca va
a entender este concepto debería darse
por vencido la comprensión de verdad
ocurrió al ver esos vídeos y también al
hacer los ejercicios del programa de
canacar de mí el impacto que tiene esto
en mí y en mi vida siento que va a
crecer exponencialmente los próximos 20
o 30 años así que desde el fondo de mi
corazón
gracias